hi everybody I'm Nancy O'Dell with an ET
special feature how do you feel out
there I feel great it was like a
out-of-body experience or a dream or
something like that it felt so great and
fun no tension it was just amazing once
it started I just float let it all go
how awesome to keep the Patty's Day
alive I think you were the only I had no
idea it was a coincidence and like we
were talking about colors yeah yeah
there's a couple days ago I was like oh
yeah pepper steak that should get us
some votes 23 million watched you bring
home the gold do you think those are
gonna be the same people watching you
bring home to dance the Mirrorball I
hope so I mean we're really proud to be
able to represent the US you know at the
Olympics it was it was a really prideful
moment and you know coming onto the show
you know we feel like we connected to
those people so we're hoping that
they'll call in and then help us out I
have to ask you you're dancing with
somebody who knows how to do it on
blades and that's so much on his feet
was there a little bit of challenge
getting him used to you know regular
wood floor yeah trying to say I guess in
the skybox is that we have a lot of work
to go he's so used to putting power into
one step and going 20 feet where is he
he goes one step so it's making that
look fluid it's a whole other technique
to learn so it's a different ball game
but he's an amazing student you know so
he's already learning so fast but what
do you think is going to be the most
difficult dance that's gonna be the most
challenging one for you there's stuff
already my head I know those different
give me some dancing to me difficult
based upon like the movement and like
you know certain the mobility is in
certain areas but um but we're working
with our processes to make sure
prosthetic legs and we're trying to come
up with some new contraptions that
literally have never been built before
and see if we can do that maybe maybe
not we don't know yet but um but it's
just forcing us to make try to get
creative with it I do want to take off
more clothes but Tony is always on my
case about me showing my personality
he's like you should show more of your
personality makes you use with your
first
so I'm gonna work on my personality I
definitely want to take off more clothes
and I'm very close to the ladies in
wardrobe hey I'm gonna have the most
fabulous outfits over all these chicks
honey we're in they're styling me booze
is your biggest competition as your
biggest competition obviously the ice
skaters obviously I mean you know I just
figure they're gonna have to do them and
we're gonna do us and we'll just have to
see what happens give me any cold less
clothes is what's gonna be what
community yeah we're doing the Samba
next week that's like you're pressing so
practically naked wearing practicing
nothing had a long winter so this is
very new to me and I was very nervous
tonight I first of all I mean I want to
do Henri proud you know he's worked with
me for two weeks to try to make that
little one minute dance look like a
Foxtrot and all I cared about was having
fun and trying to soar through it even
if I wasn't technically terrific at it
you know what do you think is gonna be
your biggest challenge do you think
Charlie is our biggest challenge no I
mean I just see my biggest challenge is
continuing as Max had to enjoy the
experience I want to learn I want to
grow I want to come away from the
experience being able to dance on the
floor and so no just kind of overcoming
my own challenges I think is what I'm
focusing on
were you even cautious about oh my gosh
my skirts coming up isn't Dancing
incredibly I was and he was like stop
stop being so self-conscious I wasn't
it's a leotard I mean like when you
watch the Olympics and gymnast were
leotard I'm just not used to being in
one in front of millions of people up in
the air upside down but you know the
spray Chan that helps the spray Chan and
the body makeup yeah that doest are
worse things was this off the top the
first thing you guys knew you were gonna
do I thought that he would not be able
to start the entire opening of Dancing
with the Stars
without this Star Wars theme I thought
it was just very
is that what made you more Cup you look
really comfortable out there on the
dance floor Billy
well she she's a very good teacher so
I've learned a great deal of working
with this wonderful young woman how
awesome like honestly you have one of
the most dynamic young young artists as
your partner this season were you
totally stoked when he walked through
the door oh my gosh I was totally stoked
I mean he's so hard-working and I didn't
know you know exactly how he was gonna
be in rehearsals but I'm so lucky to
have him as a partner you know he has a
great Twitter following obviously and a
great support system behind it so that's
definitely gonna help us in this
competition do you think that's gonna
help you against the the gold medalist
the ice skaters over here is your
Twitter following I don't know a like
I'm hoping my fans support and vote but
you know at the end of the day like it's
just a cool experience you know I can I
can take away I just you know this will
make me a better entertainer it will
introduce me to so many different dance
styles that I'd never thought that I
would ever touch on in my life